bonjour et bienvenue dans check-up le
magazine santé de la rédaction tout de
suite le sommaire en images le rythme de
l'enfant on en parle beaucoup en ce
moment et les professionnels de la
petite enfance s'interrogent Sofia c'est
le nom du dispositif pour épauler et
conseiller les maladies diabétiques
s'est mis en place par l'Assurance
Maladie une première l'association à
chef prévention a proposé une campagne
de dépistage du virus du sida au sein de
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
mais d'abord cette information qui
pourrait modifier la vie des pharmaciens
depuis la mi-février le Conseil d'État
autorisé la vente de médicaments de
certains médicaments sur Internet et
puis en même temps une chaîne de grande
distribution voudrait bien elle vendre
ses médicaments dans les magasins alors
beaucoup d'annonces pour le consommateur
mais qu'en pensent les pharmaciens début
de réponse avec ce professionnel de 50
ans en Yvelines
à partir du 1er mars toute une série de
médicaments dont la liste est très
précise seront vendues librement sur
Internet cela pourrait-il faire de
l'ombre aux pharmaciens c'est ce que
nous avons voulu savoir auprès de cet
officine ce professionnel est docteur en
pharmacie depuis 1992 il commence par
nous détailler les deux sous de la
directive européenne ça veut dire que ce
sont des sites Internet
liés relié à des pharmacies donc c'est
pas quelqu'un dans un coin qui fait un
site Internet et qui dit je vends des
médicaments non derrière le site devra
obligatoirement obligatoirement avoir un
pharmacien qui a une pharmacie
si la législation encadre donc bien la
pratique de la vente sur internet pour
se pharmacien des abus pourraient
exister maintenant on n'est pas à l'abri
de faux sites on n'est pas à l'abri de
sites qui seraient éventuellement
hébergé à l'étranger qui permettrait de
d'avoir des boîtes enfin bref on n'est
pas à l'abri de scandale sanitaire
demain comme on peut en entendre parler
au niveau de la nourriture attention au
low cost attention au prix pas cher
c'est-à-dire à la qualité pas cher voire
pas qualité du tout donc ma crainte elle
est juste sur la notion de qualité et de
sécurité elle est pas sur le reste le
reste c'est un canal de distribution de
communication comme les autres à nous
pharmaciens de prendre ce canal de
distribution de l'utiliser à bon escient
la vente libre de médicaments sur
Internet actuellement en France un seul
pharmacien la pratique en tout cas ce
praticien lui n'ira pas sur ce terrain
au nom de la proximité vis-à-vis de ses
clients mais il reconnaît une nécessité
pour la profession de s'adapter il a
fait le choix de s'associer avec trois
autres pharmacies pour proposer des
tarifs moins élevés donc compétitifs
indispensable selon lui pour éviter que
le marché de la vente libre des
médicaments ne soit récupérés par la
grande distribution comme cela était le
cas il y a quelques années avec la
parapharmacie
et le gouvernement a annoncé fin février
sa volonté que les médicaments vendus
sur Internet soit plus cher que dans les
officines allez le rythme des enfants on
en parle beaucoup en ce moment et
notamment évidemment sur le plan
scolaire mais c'est une préoccupation
également du monde de la petite enfance
et une réunion sur ce thème a eu lieu à
Trappes
si petit est déjà au cœur des débats la
ville de Trappes a organisé son premier
rendez-vous entre professionnels de la
petite enfance et parents l'occasion
d'échanger sur les rythmes et les
espaces de vie du jeune enfant
je travaille en crèche et c'est vrai que
c'était c'est très très intéressant par
rapport à mon travail au niveau des
enfants et c'est vrai que ça nous fait
beaucoup de rappel aussi sur ce qu'on a
appris avant puis bon on se rend compte
que c'est loin d'être la réalité
impersonnel trop peu nombreux pour
accueillir toujours plus d'enfants et
c'est la liberté d'épanouissement des
tout-petits qui se trouve amputés de
plus auxiliaire animateur et assistante
maternelle sont trop peu formés à
l'éducation des 0,6 ans
collective entre différents services ça
peut être intéressant on est tous la
même pédagogie on démarche vis-à-vis des
enfants
respecter le rythme de renfort
de faire tout seul s'asseoir en même
temps pour faire une activité c'est pas
forcément bon laissez l'enfant jouer et
être initiateur de son jeu pour lui
donner confiance en lui plutôt que
d'être encadré et orienté par les
adultes c'est le souhait des
professionnels présents ce jour-là la
France est en retard sur certaines des
questions en tout cas sur l'éducation et
sur le fait de
laisser les plus petits jouer le plus
longtemps possible dès qu'il
franchissent je dirais la porte de
l'école en fait ils sont formatés pour
pouvoir répondre aux demandes des
enseignants et de pouvoir être préparé
pour leur enseignement ils deviennent
très tôt des élèves changer les modes
d'accueil des enfants et les
individualiser ce sont les pistes de
travail de la ville de Trappes qui a
proposé des débats tout au long du mois
de février
depuis quelques semaines les diabétiques
des Yvelines ont reçu un courrier de la
CPAM du département leur proposant
d'adhérer au dispositifs Sofia un
dispositif d'accompagnement gratuit dans
l'agglomération 50 chinoise trappe et la
verrière sont les communes les plus
concernées par cette maladie chronique
décryptage
depuis début février les diabétiques des
Yvelines ont reçu un courrier de leur
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie les
incitant à s'inscrire au programme Sofia
un programme d'accompagnement gratuit
basé sur le volontariat ils vont
bénéficier d'un accompagnement de la
part de l'Assurance Maladie un
accompagnement à distance à la fois par
le biais d'envoi de documents de livrer
de fiches conseils mais également un
accompagnement téléphonique relayé par
nos infirmières conseils
ils peuvent ainsi obtenir des conseils
alimentaires des conseils en matière
d'exercices physiques et même un rappel
pour le suivi de leur rendez-vous
médicaux André Kléber et président de la
Maison du diabète des Yvelines il est
donc bien informé et pourtant ce service
pourrait lui être bien utile surtout
dans les moments de découragement de
temps en temps c'est difficile de dire
il faut que j'aille voir le cardiologue
il faut que j'aille voir le phlébologue
il faut que ça devienne des réflexes
et avant que ça devienne des réflexes
quand on fait beaucoup d'autres choses
on peut oublier
et quand on fait quand on reste seul
avec son diabète alors là c'est encore
plus triste parce qu'on n'a pas le
courage d'y aller
Sofia existe en France depuis 2008 il a
déjà été mis en place dans 19
départements et le constat et le suivant
les patients prennent mieux en charge
leur maladie dans les Yvelines plus de
35000 personnes ont reçu ce courrier à
50 ans en Yvelines 6000 diabétiques sont
concernées à noter que les enfants
n'entrent pas dans le cadre du
dispositif
pour la première fois une opération de
dépistage du virus du ciné était
organisé au sein de l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin proposé
conjointement par l'association
Icare et HF prévention elle a concerné
près de 90 étudiants
Marie-France est retraité elle est
bénévole au sein d'un chef prévention et
à la participé à l'opération dépistage
du VIH au sein de l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin avant le test
minutes les étudiants répondent à des
questions concernant notamment leur
pratique sexuelles
nous on n'est pas les parents avec les
parents peut-être ils vont pas discuter
de tout ça avec des personnes comme nous
ça nous dérange pas et puis s'ils ont
envie de parler bien sûr oui à aucun
problème après le questionnaire il est
donc possible de bénéficier d'un test
gratuit une minute pour savoir pour
montrer aux gens qu'il faut que tout le
monde puisse lui que tout le monde
puisse faire ce test c'est très
important c'est très rapide en plus ça
fait pas mal
et puis bon c'est une bonne un bon moyen
d'éviter d'aller faire une prise de sang
c'est la première fois cachef prévention
organise une opération de dépistage
rapide à l'université en partenariat
avec l'association d'étudiants Icare et
ce n'est pas anodin on ressent quand
même un besoin des étudiants de se faire
dépister sur leur lieu étant donné que
ils ont pas toujours les moyens de se
déplacer il faut prendre le train à
Trappes les rendez-vous c'est que le
jeudi soir donc c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu problématique avec leur emploi
du temps c'est des étudiants qui sont
très au courant il y a des étudiants qui
ont proposé des pistaches qui nous
disent ah bah non moi c'est fait je l'ai
fait il y a deux mois il y a pas de
problème et puis on croise aussi des
étudiants qui nous disent ah non moi je
me protège pas je vois pas à quoi ça
sert les étudiants c'est le cœur de
cible tout comme effectivement les
populations homosexuelles ou les situer
les les populations donc précaires ou
migrants effectivement les jeunes font
partie des priorités en tout cas des
nouvelles priorités donc du gouvernement
et on se retrouve effectivement avec des
jeunes qui sont inquiets de leur statut
serrurlogique c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle de voir qu'ils ont une prise de
conscience sur donc les risques sexuels
l'idée pour un chef prévention c'est
d'intervenir plus régulièrement à
l'université à raison d'une fois tous
les deux mois l'association est
également hébergée au sein de l'Institut
de promotion de la santé à Trappes en
une journée de présence à l'UVSQ 85
jeunes se sont fait dépister tous
négatifs
inter-entreprise vient d'ouvrir à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux elle peut
accueillir une trentaine d'enfants elle
est réservée aux parents salariés
d'entreprises du quartier d'activité du
pas du Lacan regarde
mon tipi c'est la quatrième crèche
inter-entreprise de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ouvert depuis
le 2 janvier la crèche du groupe people
and baby peut accueillir 31 enfants
âgé de trois mois à 4 ans les enfants
sont séparés en deux sections petit
moyen et moyen grand
Fanny la maman de Matteo 4 ans est
enthousiaste il est beaucoup plus
épanoui on sent qu'il a envie de venir
il fait des choses il a des activités
qui lui sont proposées et c'est ce qui
lui mangeait en fait chez la nourrice
déjà l'environnement ils arrivent c'est
pas une télé un canapé c'est des jeux
voilà on leur propose du dessin de la
peinture c'est c'est vraiment adapté
pour eux
mon tipi à Montigny-le-Bretonneux est
uniquement accessible aux parents
salariés de la Banque Populaire
val-de-france et du groupe Bouygues
Construction avec des horaires flexibles
8 heures 19 heures la crèche souhaite
offrir des services supérieurs au crèche
municipale
l'architecture de la crèche c'est très
bien pensé on a un matériel
pédagogique
on est énormément gâté et on a des
professionnels diplômés ce qui n'est pas
le cas dans toutes les structures dans
toutes les crèches vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'habiter la commune pour avoir
une place votre seul contrainte à vous
finalement c'est que soit le papa soit
la maman fasse partie de partie d'une
entreprise qui réserve des places et
vous êtes sûr d'avoir votre place de du
tout petit âge du bébé jusqu'à ce qu'ils
partent à l'école et ça c'est super
parce que bon bah voilà c'est c'est ça
ça rentrait serein et l'enfant et le
parent bien sûr
pour les parents le tarif est le même
que pour les crèches municipales il
varie de 87 centimes d'euros à 2 euros
83 par heure selon les revenus et le
barème fixé par la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales couches soin et alimentation
bio tout est fourni l'entreprise
adhérente elle cotise à la hauteur du
nombre de places réservées
allez avant de nous quitter noter ces
trois rendez-vous santé l'Établissement
français du sang dite de France organise
à régulièrement des collègues les
prochaines auront lieu notamment à
Montigny Bois-d'Arcy et plaisir toutes
les informations sur le site Internet du
don du sang l'Institut de promotion de
la santé de Trappes accueille
régulièrement les expositions de l'ARS
l'Agence régionale de la santé la
prochaine sera consacrée aux addictions
elle se déroule à partir de la mi-mars
et puis stress et mal-être au travail un
va se débat et une conférence proposée
par Yvelines Santé Travail ce sera le 21
mars à voisin le bretonné check-up c'est
fini merci de votre attention prochain
rendez-vous du magazine santé ce sera
dans un mois d'ici là portez-vous bien